اناقه وجمال اخاذ وجه حسن اصبح الاكثر
شهره عالميه سيده جاءت من وينس ايرس لتحت
لقلب رونالدو وعقله المليء بكره القدم
وحماساتها جورجينا رودريغيز الحسناء
الارجنتينيه التي استطاعت خطف قلب الدون
من نظره الاولى التي جمعتهما مصادفه
ولتكون شركه حياته بكل ما فيها من بذوق
واحلام سعيده السيده القادمه من عالم
الهامش استطاعه ان تكون احد اشهر نساء
العالم بسنوات قليله مستفيده من علاقتها
بالنجم البرتغالي فضلا عن جمالها الساحر
الذي قادها الى عالم الازياء والتمثيل وما
التغيرات الاخيره وانتقار رونالدو الى
النصر السعودي اصبح الجورجينا تحت انذار
العالم في المنطقه العربيه لتكون في
اسبوعها الاول في الرياض شخصيه الاسبوع
اللي نتعرف عليها اكثر اليوم
هلا هي اوك كثير حلوه جورجينا بس اكيد الي
كاتب الخبر شب لانه كذا مره الجمال الساحر
جمال الاخد عبد السلام عم بيقولوا لي تحيه
نتعرف معانا على قصه جورجيا
صدفه غريبه وجميله كانت الحسناء
الارجنتينيه جورجينا رودريغيز على موعد
معها حين دخل عليها النجم البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو في متجر غوتشي حيث كانت
تعمل كبائعه يلتقيان لاول مره وتبدا
بينهما قصه حب عظيمه اصبحت على مراه
العالم منذ ذلك الحين هذا الحب اصبح باب
السعاده جورجينا التي لم تكن قبل التاريخ
لقائها برونالدو صاحبه شهره لتنتقل بعد
حبهما الى عالم الشهره وتصبح احد اهم وجوه
الازياء والدعايه في العالم لم تغيب
جورجينا عن حياه شركه رونالدو رياضيه في
كل لحظاتها الجميله منها والسيئه كانت معه
ايام احتفاله بدوري الابطال مع ريال مدريد
لعده سنوات وكانت جزءا من الفرح الخاص به
حين توج مع بلاده بكاس امم اوروبا ودور
الامم الاوروبيه وايضا كانت معه
التي بدات منذ خرج من اسبانيا واكتملت في
مانشستر يونايتد وصلت الى ذروتها عاقبه
خروج المؤلم كاس العالم جورجينا كانت ايضا
خير لرونالدو في اصعب اللحظات حين راى
منافسه الاول عالميا ليونيل ميسي يتوج
بكاس العالم فهي الارجنتينيه التي لم
تحتفل بفوز بلادها بالبطوله الاكبر حفاظا
على مشاعر شريكها البرتغاليه الجانب الاخر
من حياه جورجينا مع رونالدو انها سيده
منزل ماهره فهي طالما ظهرت بمقاطع فيديو
وهي تعتني في منزلها ايضا وايضا باطفالهم
حتى الذين لم تنجبهم الحسناء الارجنتينيون
[موسيقى]
على كلن ينضم الينا من دبي عمار شهاب خبير
لغات الجسد لنكشف لغه الجسد جورجينا اليوم
عمار اهلا بك يسعد صباحك الله يعينك
[موسيقى]
صباح الورد
بطريقه
اشخاص يعني
كانت اقوى من ميسي عفوا اقوى من رونالدو
بظهورها كونها هي بتشتغل بموضوع الموديلنج
وبتعرف تمشي على ستيج وبتعرف تفوت امام
الكاميرا
بحدث كبير مثل هذا لاول مره هما مش معتدين
اصلا يصير هيك استقبال كلهم على مستوى
العالم باي فعاليات اخرى
عمار هي جميله جدا ام ان لغه جسدها قويه
جدا لتجذب الملايين وتصبح اسطوره مثل
كريستيانو
مشيتها القويه واعتمادها على شركتها مع
شريكها هو اللي خلاها قادره تبرز نفسها
وتستثمر هذا الشيء بطريقه صحيحه بذكاء
طبعا
رونالدو متيم بحسناء كيف تشوف لغه الجسد
جورجينا فيها
رونالدو عم بحاول يعني اكيد صار في
مناقشات للموضوع وظهورها لانه كان كثير
درس الموضوع بالثقافه الاسلاميه والعربيه
بشكل اوسط
وعامله دراسه كويس وكان محترمه جدا
بظهورها بهذه الطريقه
وهذا المكان غريب عليهم اصلا
ومع ذلك كان ميسي يعني عفوا كان رونالدو
عم يحاول انه هو يعني يشوف رضاعها هل هي
مرتاحه بالهيئه جديده تبعها لانه بيعرفوا
طبيعتها فهو هون كان مرتبك اكثر منها
بصراحه
الثانيه هلا معك
والصوره الثانيه اللي راح نشوفها لجورجينا
الان مع العائله كريستيانو رونالدو
عم شوف معنى عمار
امام العائله وحواليها الاطفال طبعا
حقيقيه
وهذه اللغه
طبعا جميل جدا انه قدرت تورج قوتها على
المسرح وتحتوي همم المشهد كاملا وطبعا هذا
الشيء تظهر امام الملايين بمدرش بهذه
الزخامه فقط
لو سمحتوا
طيب كريستيانو هالمره معاهم عمار اني كانت
مع اولادها بالاول معها كريستيانو كيف
تفسر لغه جسدها والعائله معاها
انا مش متدربه ولا بتعرف بل
لغه لانها كانت قادره تفرجي طمانينه
وبالراحه تبعها
ويبدا عليها الراحه عكس ما يتداول اليوم
بوسائط التواصل الاجتماعي كان قادره تعمل
يعني رسائل انه هي مرتاحه انه هي قادره
انه تنفذ مهمتها بطريقه كويسه
رغم انه كريستيانو رونالدو ما كان بهذه
الصوره
الصوره اللي بعدها عمار لحظه وصولهم الى
المطار بنشوف مع بعض جورجينا وماسكه باقه
الورد واستقبال كانه شوي في ارتباك بالاول
واضح جدا
مع بعضهم في ارتباك انهم واقفين بطريقه
معينه وطريقه التقديم كانت فيها ارتباك
واضح وكمان هذا الشيء يعني ظروف المحيطه
فيهم اللي هي وين هم يعملوا هيك حقيقي
طيب هي بتحيي الجمهور جمهور النصر بعد ما
طلب منها رونالدو ترفع ايدها وشفنا هذا
الفيديو
[موسيقى]
يعني بصراحه كانت
بالاول وقفه ملكه قدرت تنفذ مهمتها بطريقه
حلوه بجوز تكون مش مدربين هم على هذا
اللحظه بالضبط همم
بطريقه كويسه
وبذلك يعني كانت بالعكس كثير كثير زهور
يعني ظهور جميل ومشرف ان هي تقدر تعمل هذا
الشيء بيوصل جديد عليها تماما لاول مره من
هذا الحفل الكبير من من الناس مش طبيعي
انه يقدر يعملوا هذا الشيء بطريقه قويه
ولكن كان طبيعتها وان هي شخص همم مرتاح
كان قادرين يعملوا همم هذه المؤشرات
بطريقه كويسه
شكرا لك من دبي عمار الشام خبير في لغه
الجسد